the gentleman's radish i've never heard
of this in my life delicious on hot
toast but you seem to have given me
crackers
so
i don't know how this will be
that is
it looks like when you've had a really
dodgy curry
[Music]
[Applause]
hey i'm laura whitmore and this is snack
wars ireland versus the uk so we are
doing ireland today because
shakari ready for this
i'm actually irish i know this is a real
accent yeah yeah
not even putting it on big reveal today
oh my god i love how much effort went
into this crisp sandwich didn't even
bother taking it out of the packet i
mean
this is so easy do i have
give it a little try it's got pickle on
it
of course i don't know how i feel about
pickle on a sandwich you actually might
like it
better than i thought
i like cheese
i like pickle i like my bread i would
normally put them together like this
it's okay however i mean do you expect
me just to do this
okay so this is how
i've talked about this before because
i'm really particular when it comes to
making a crisp sandwich so i like my
crisps i'm just dry
it's a bit like a game of tetris because
can you get the whole packet because
some people just do that and then you
just
put the whole packet in always get the
little bits
get the little bits
little bits
now the best thing about this is the
crunch
okay
wait for it
[Applause]
asmr alone and then we go straight in
now this isn't really a first date kind
of thing because it's not going to be
pretty but here we go
every time choose an onion potato
between two slices of bread
that wins i'm sorry whatever this is
not
i have quite a supply of this in my
house
i feel like uk you're going down
what's this the gentleman's radish i've
never heard of this in my life delicious
on hot toast but you seem to have given
me crackers
so
i don't know how this will be
looks like a pate
oh
god it's a real task to get in there
isn't it
that is nice
it looks like
it looks like when you've had a really
dodgy curry okay so use fairly i think
this is going to be quite potent this is
going to be strong
oh jeez
do you know what it smells like
fish food
do you know that no i'm not lies it
smells like fish food that's good enough
for the fish it's good enough for me
okay
mmm
tastes like fish food too
this stuff is incredible i've actually
been to bali malo house um
you can have this with everything i kind
of have instead of tomato ketchup
it's fresh as well well done
um
i just feel like this is the closest
i got to like you know when you can't
kids don't eat but they're vegetables
this is the closest thing just give them
a pot of this and a spoon there's enough
tomatoes in there
i'm gonna try something
a bit mad i'm gonna put some
on my gentleman's relish
okay wow
yeah that doesn't really work
that was all right it wasn't as bad as
it looks but this is just
every home should have one of these
this is just beautiful
oh
oh
i mean
eog right here how can we even compare
anything
what is this oh it's a pale ale with a
bottle opener am i using my teeth
because i probably could use my teeth
do you want to try no
okay
smooth and refreshing bursting with
flavor old speckled hem i mean it's not
the most appetizing of names
it's all right
now
i love guinness but it should never be
drank from a can like this
do you have a glass
okay quite a pint glass but it's um
oh my god there's a few instagram
accounts of like
um
guinnesses like so if you pour them yeah
so i'm gonna probably be on that
um this is not the way to do it
although maybe i'll make myself a new
little drinker i mean that's absolutely
horrific
um
yes oh wow this is how you pour again so
then in about 20 minutes time that will
be ready to drink um
you don't understand i can never go to
ireland again if this gets shown
what why is this so frothy
i might just drink it from the can
i'll say it once and i'll say it again a
meal in the glass first time i tasted
guinness i hated it it's a real acquired
taste but um a guinness i can't no again
a skin is a million times over
this is such i'm having such a good time
here guys
i will come back anytime so we've got
scotch whiskey we do like scotch whiskey
in our house bailey look at this just
reminds me of christmas and my mom and
all my aunts i don't know why it's when
you reach a certain age in ireland you
drink this i just i love whiskey i do
love a whiskey
this is a good one it's from scotland
i've had this before
i know you're supposed to measure with
the rums and do a lower measure measure
there you go
love it there you go the ice
see what i love about we drink whiskey
quite a lot i just really i don't know
you can
sip this you can take your time with it
you don't have to drink it too fast i
think back in the day i used to kind of
have like a whiskey and coke and now i
feel as i'm getting older i can just
have a straight whiskey and it's fine
i'm a big fan of that
i'm a big fan of that
so
i really like bailey's the problem with
bailey's is it brings back some bad
memories of um when i was younger
and my friends would come over we'd get
ready for a night out and we'd go to my
mom's drinks cabinet to see what's left
that you can drink
so i drank bailey's not the way you
should drink bailey's bailey should be
after a meal you know it's a it's a
lovely dessertly cure it should not be
drank in a pint glass
before you go on a out if you mix it
with certain drinks it curdles as i've
learned
this reminds me of christmas
this is love it's really nostalgic
is just delicious like it's really tasty
so it's going to be babies i do love
whiskey but you can't compete with
babies like it's an irish cream it's
lovely island wins
i don't know why irish people always
sing that song because it's not irish
but oh they yeah i knew they were going
to win we just do everything better what
can i say
am i light open
give me a hand oh okay i'm going to get
out of shot and reveal oh okay i thought
that was the food i was like it's so
hard
i'm gonna break a tooth
oh
oh my god i hate that that's too far
from